campagne présidentielle en france
eh bien on est à j moins 3 mise au point
et déclarations se multiplient même si
l'activité proprement dite des candidats
semble avoir marqué le pas aujourd'hui
valéry giscard d'estaing n'a tenu aucun
meeting il se prépare demain un rapide
tour de l'hexagone françois mitterrand
pour sa part avait réuni aujourd'hui à
paris une grande partie des élus
socialistes nationaux régionaux et 2009
24 heures avant la clôture de la
campagne officielle cette campagne
électorale vient de prendre un ton tout
à fait abrupte avec une violente attaque
portée par françois mitterrand contre
son adversaire profitant d'une réunion
les élus socialistes à la salle de
lempiras paris françois mitterrand a
demandé à valéry giscard d'estaing de
garder à la campagne un ton digne et il
a accusé d'avoir lire soir dans son
émission et 12 mensonge en vingt huit
monsieur giscard d'estaing a cherché
pendant sept ans à tromper les français
sur sa politique
il veut maintenant les tromper sur la
mienne je relève en effet dans ses
dernières déclarations télévisées
celle d'hier soir en particulier qu à
mesure qu'approche la fin de cette
campagne électorale il n'hésite pas pour
faire oublier son lourd bilan à
m'attaquer en brandissant le mensonge et
la peur il ne dit pas la vérité
et il le sait quand il prétend que je
veux taxé par exemple le logement des
français il ne dit pas la vérité
et il le sait quand il prétend que je
veux fonctionnarisé la médecine et les
pharmacies il ne dit pas la vérité et il
le sait quand il prétend que je veux
supprimer la retraite des cadres
il ne dit pas la vérité et il le sait
quand il prétend que je n'aurai pas la
liberté d'agir en matière de politique
étrangère
or l'une des premières vertu d'un
président de la république et de dire la
vérité au pays
j'ai fait des propositions précises je
ne suis engagé que par les propositions
que j'ai fait moi-même ou comptent
exprimer en mon nom mais représente
devant la gravité de ces attaques
mensongères
j'ai décidé de consacrer
l'émission télévisée de ce soir jeudi 7
mai à répondre point par point
je le ferai avec gravité avec sévérité
12 mensonge en 20 minutes
je suis bien qu'il n'a pas eue hier soir
battu son record
mais cela ne l'autorisent pas continuer
sur cette voie sans que je me dresse
face à lui avec votre concours pour le
montrer du doigt un président de la
république jeudi faudrait-il plus que de
trois jours exercer cette fonction n'a
pas le droit de compromettre la
démocratie et le pays dans un combat
sordide de ce type
je demande à monsieur giscard d'estaing
qu'ils veuillent bien au non du mandat
qu'il exerce encore revenir à une
campagne dit conforme à l'image que les
français se font de la dignité cette
fonction et du rôle qui incombe à celui
qu'il occupe
quant à moi respectueux de la vérité de
la vérité telle que je la ressens est
telle que je m'exprime
ce sera ma ligne de conduite jusqu'au
cou